what's good y'all you already The Vibes
we doing the things that we like to do
with bootleg Kev podcast listen make
sure you tune in you
heard yo man the bootleg Kev podcast we
in the building we got a special guest
here her new album just dropped Dennis
daughter uhuh uh Lola Brook is here
what's good Kev what's going on working
how's it feel to finally get this album
out it feel like a lot of
it's it's like a lot of closure you know
this the first chapter closing out it's
time to get to it's time to get to work
for the next one you know how this go
right it just don't stop what's like you
know I feel like people really been
waiting for your debut project you know
what I'm saying like I feel like this
has been a highly anticipated thing
going on yeah and I didn't want to just
give anything and I wanted to make sure
I put my oil on it and I wanted to make
sure I knew exactly what I wanted to
talk about and where I was coming from
as artist for sure yeah no for sure uh
and for you Dennis is your father I hope
right yes I would hope so thank Dennis
daughter yes Dennis is I mean that's a
pretty personal like title for your your
debut you
know I
mean what other way I wouldn't have no
other way as a artist a lot of people
connect with you because you have a
story to tell that they can relate to so
I'm pretty sure when people come to
their family functions they be like oh
that's such and such daughter that's
such and such son that's how you
introduce kids to you know oh oh she got
big so I feel like everybody could
relate to that what part of Brooklyn you
from the star bed star bed star you
heard do it's it's getting a little uh
is it getting a little like uh hipstery
over there yeah like the park that I
grew up in people done lost their life
there all types of stuff happened out
there and now people got walking their
dogs in there having picnics and I last
time I was in New York I stayed in um
Bushwick and I was just like this is
crazy oh yeah Bushwick started first for
because to Williamsburg yeah well I like
been to Williamsburg and that [__] is
like wild like Whole Foods shoers you
know people who wear Tom shoes and [__]
live there you know but like you know
bedy is getting there too bed definitely
getting there I'm I mean I'm I'm not mad
at it because I still have family
members that's out there so the safer
the better honestly for sure yeah did
you move out you got a out of course I
had two I had no choice I didn't want to
but I had no choice did you do the
Jersey thing yeah did
you know how New York is do oh I know
they don't go too far I can't stay too
far Jersey is is good enough for me I
that's last time I was in New York I was
hanging out in uh Coney Island with nms
yeah yeah oh Bing Bong that guy yeah
stupid yeah which is like that's like
the outskirts of Brooklyn it's like
pretty deep it took us for [__] ever
to get there it was like from where
though I don't where we at we're in
Manhattan
oh but I didn't
way you take but yeah it's it can't feel
like it's pretty I didn't realize y'all
don't have like a Walmart like you got
you got to go to Long Island right yeah
we don't have no Walmart in Brooklyn n
that does not there's not a Walmart
anywhere no what is like because you got
to understand we got corner stores and
corner stores is like grocery stores but
Walmart is cheap yeah but W Walmart too
expensive to be you guys have a full
size do you have a fullsize Target yeah
we got yeah Target yeah Target is our
go-to for sure but no Walmarts n no have
you ever been inside of a Walmart past
10 p.m. in life like on the road maybe
on the road yeah Walmart's a wild place
but yeah and now I'm in Jersey so they
got Walmart and Jersey mhm Jersey is
like a little different right yeah it is
it is drive through certain parts it's
like kind of like country like Vibes you
know what I'm saying that's how I feel
cuz it's like I drove the Buffalo from
New York City and I was like we're in
Jersey this [__] looks like [__]
Amish town you know it make you feel
like like you you you you get can get
away from the trenches but Jersey got
the trenches too Jersey has the trenches
they do yes they do shout out to Jersey
shout out to Jersey yo what was that
movie New Jersey Drive New Jersey where
all the cars was getting stolen yeah
they steal cars like that's a thing out
there they steal cars yeah no Jersey's
wild shout out to Jersey shout outs to
Jersey yeah I mean for you like uh I
feel like you kind of kick the door down
in terms of like this new energy out of
New York being a female and like kind of
carrying that flag um it's been a couple
of years since don't playw it originally
came out right yes but then it kind of
like nationally went crazy about 10
months ago is that right right you you
you on point um for you like to come out
and like have that record like kind of
be like a old record that not
necessarily old but a record that had
been out for a while but really kind of
like finally get some life to it it's
such a massive song the remix was big it
felt like such a big moment um some
people get a record like that and it's
like the music becomes bigger the song
becomes bigger bigger than the artist
how have you been able to avoid that cuz
I saw you you did my club in a and and
everybody was singing all your [__] the
thing about don't play with it don't
play with it went viral not because of
someone else did like a viral Tik Tok to
it it went viral because of me being on
screen performing the song so thank God
for that that that's what made it take
off is seeing me um perform on From the
Block yeah I remember that and that's
yeah shout outs to From the Block shout
out to From the Block what do they do
with that mic is the mic how they hang
it what doing is it is it yeah is it a
ladder what's going on with that
microphone I like a little setup it's
like you know like what you use for like
backdrops I don't I mean I don't know
the proper word for it it's probably one
of those things but right and then it
just hangs yeah okay I always wondered I
was like dude they got two ladders and
someone's just standing up I used to I
was wondering the same thing and then
when I got there I was like oh okay cool
this is cute cute um for you uh give me
kind of like a you know this is a
important album for you what is if
someone were to press play on this
outside of the single shout out to
Bryson tiller you got the brys but what
what's your favorite song what's like
the go-to like what's the song that
embodies
Lola I am Lola and bodies Lola that's
the intro yeah it's well it's it's not
the intro
but it it it it sounds like it could
have been the intro wait what's the
intro isn't the intro is intro um 2023
flow oh maybe I'm tripping because I
used to do these consistent freestyles
for my fans so I do 2017 flow 201 the
ler record has like a sample though kind
of with your name in it
right okay yeah yeah so it's basically
me saying I'm the one like this is not a
mistake I'm a true artist I I I came
very far I spoke about where I'm coming
from how long I've worked how hard I've
worked and taking not for answer so that
embodies Lola for real I am Lola give me
some of the uh the story like how long
has this cuz a lot of people look at you
like you're a new artist but you ain't
like you ain't new to this like how long
has this grind been for you I'm not new
I've been working on music even let me
just say this 2017 is when I was like
I'mma take this serious serious like I
resign for my job serious was that job
residential Aid at a shelter so I was
just cat catering to clients homeless
people homeless people yeah and my mom
got me the job so [__] hits the fan you
could always move to LA and help us with
this homeless problem no for real and
it's so crazy I wanted to go back to the
facility that I was working at but they
closed it down oh damn yeah so that kind
of like broke my heart but my mom got me
the job there so I was explaining to her
like I always wanted to go back to give
back but they shut down the facility and
I don't know how I'm going get the names
and she was like she help me out you go
down to Downtown LA uh Skid Row tons of
giving back to do down there just you
got to dodge the fentanyl smoke it's
rough down there it's rough like that oh
yeah it's bad [__] everywhere human [__]
everywhere fentanyl just I've never I've
seen it online cuz you know crazy I've
seen it online it's like The
Purge like we were driving down there
like last week mhm and like looked to
the right and there's just like five
fires in the middle of the
street like people warming their hands
and [__] like almost like a ninja turtle
movie like from the '90s you know like
it feels like the type of place Shredder
with um just like uh the movie
and it was a scene where it was like
homeless people warming up with a fire
there's a lot of those scenes yeah like
you know like uh Joe pesi in Home Alone
it's a bunch of guys over there yeah but
you know see me growing up I'm thinking
that's like a old scenario but it's
still going on today it's lit over here
for sure crazy they just set the freeway
on fire the t's closed
down so if you ever have you tried to go
downtown since you've been in La I've
been downtown but I'm talking about this
trip like two days ago no no no no no
there was like an explosion under the
bridge like under the 10 and they they V
they they think it was some homeless
[__] going on under there that went
rough and then there was a big fire so
the freeways closed down indefinitely
the 10 in
La it's rough out here it's [__] up
yeah it's crazy damn I'm going to say
this like I went to New York and we're
everywhere in New York I was like yo
it's nice out here I was like maybe we
saw like 12 homeless dudes it was nice
it's not no see compare La compared to
New York City yeah yeah you would be
like oh it's cool in New York but the
people that live in New York it's like
it's certain places where do you guys
like Eric Adams the mayor like what is
he a nice guy like what are your
thoughts I've never met him but I mean
listen I just saw he was in like he had
to give his phone to the feds so I don't
know what's going on I peep that yeah I
peep that but Hey listen I just pray my
boy doing right by the city me too he
seems like he's
like yeah but um everybody
everybody have their way of showing um
who they are and I just pray that
whatever he got going on he could defend
himself we just went on a wild tangent
because you're explaining to me you quit
your job in 2017 and then we started
talking about fed all continue your
story 2017 you quit your job 2017 you
did it 27 2017 I quit my job February
14th I I didn't quit hold on fix that I
did not quit my job I resigned from my
job so if I wanted to go back to my job
today I can good okay right I don't burn
Bridges regardless of what's my journey
or what I feel like my future is to to
bring um I don't burn Bridges you know
what I'm saying so yeah I resigned from
my job my mom actually supported me
through it ni she was like look listen I
see you going in and out the house no
sleep Studio work if you feel like you
need to leave so that you could really
dig down into your your Artistry do so
and she got me the job so it was a it I
just felt like it was arms opened for
her to say because you know when it come
down to Mommy every you get a little I
did not just make them calls get you
that job for you for you to quit right
right right right so I'm like all right
she said we just going to do it the
right way you going to resign and then
my mentor 80 shout outs to team 80 he
supported me too financially as well so
so what was like I had a good support
system after you went all time like
fulltime rather how long did it take for
you to realize like uh you could make
this your career like you could actually
like oh this is working like I made some
money I got paid to do this I maybe you
got paid to do a future maybe you got
paid to do a show or uh it wasn't money
for me it was just how it made me feel
so my teammate that's a part of Team 80
his name is bzy he's an artist from
Brownsville he wanted to do brv shout
out to Brownsville it's rough out in
Browns if you should they should have
took you to Brownsville it's still
Brownsville never Chang I've heard
that's the only place that hasn't been
gentrified yeah in Brownsville Brooklyn
New York it's crazy out there Fame and
Billy Dan just hanging out on the corner
still it's wild no for real like it's
wild out there like nothing has changed
I think
um 41's from there right the 41 people
uh uh I think so but I don't want to be
I don't want to say they but I know it's
Brooklyn for sure so he asked to get me
on a song for a feature I came through
you had ad there Uncle M was there shout
out Uncle Mayo uh and you say uncle Mayo
yeah I call him Uncle Mane he's a nice
Uncle yeah he is a he's crazy so I did
the song I ended up meeting the team
which is team0 I met everybody and I
just fell in love with just being in the
studio because where I came from I I
couldn't afford studio time I couldn't
afford videos I wasn't even thinking
about doing videos cuz I ain't I wasn't
financially stable to do so and I just
was around it I just felt good I'm like
yo you know what this could be this
could be a thing for me and then my my
dad just had passed and um I remember my
best friend saying like you was you
you're depressed I didn't know I was
depressed but she was like you're
depressed and ever since you start
taking music serious like you like you
shift it's kind of made you happy yes it
made me happy so being around them made
me so happy just seeing ad put his
artist DOD was his art his artist he put
them through artist development did
music videos um in a studio night and
day going out to the clubs promoting
music and I never got to see that part
of it so I'm like oh this is this is
fire but it was no I wasn't making no
money it just was something to you saw
the light at the end of the tunnel
you're like oh this is yeah yeah so then
yeah I tapped into it like that who are
your uh you know growing up in Brooklyn
who your who your goats who are you like
uh who's on the wall for you uh you got
Kim you got Fox Jay-Z
biggie those are good four yeah it is
Uncle boa all right wait we got to stop
the interview this is an emergency my
bookie just sent me an email this week
is Thanksgiving week and we have an
emergency offer sign up at
mybookie.ag we're going to have so much
football to bet on Thanksgiving how
about all the NBA that's going to be
happening on Black Friday oh football
weekend is going to be crazy and right
now this is very exclusive to the
bootleg C podcast they're doing a
110% deposit bonus that's right this
bonus offer is 110% deposit match up to
11 $100 that means if you deposit
$11,000 you will get
$1,100 for free put right into your
account to gamble with what are we doing
go to mybookie right now my bookie right
now sign up use the promo code bootleg
and this only is going on until November
26 that's Sunday all right so from now
till Sunday if you sign up in my bookie
you're going to get
110% to deposit match uh bonus all right
that means you put in 1,000 you're going
to get ,100 you put in 100 you're going
to get $110 did I do that right my M
[__] all right but listen shout out to
mybookie all right sign up mybookie.ag
use that promo code bootleg this is so
exclusive y'all this is only happening
this week so make sure you sign up if
you like to gamble like me let's get
this money baby all right also want to
give a shout out to our family our new
sponsor shout out to Munchies man it's
Thanksgiving we love the munchies baby
all right want to give a shout out to
Munchies the market leader in the hemp
and cannabis space of course offering
you federally legal award-winning hemp
products that are comparable to your
favorite cannabis products all right and
it can get shipped straight to your door
and check this out the craziest sale of
the year so much going on so many
products I love the strawberry dream
gummies let's pop these boys open all
right this was dope the biggest sale of
the Year 40% off any order 40% off any
order of $60 or more right now if you go
to their website go to delt munchies.
comom use the promo code bootleg or
bootleg cev you can use either one of
those bootleg bootleg cev all together
you're going to get 40% off any order
this is what's dope about their gummies
all right their gummies are so good 100
milligrams per gummy so you see all
these there's 1,000 milligrams in the
box they're vegan they're made with real
fruit and the flavors are crazy you've
seen the strawberry dream they also got
the apple berry nectar and this one
right here the tropical passion all
right and let's not forget that they
also got the Vapes for you yeah that's
right this is the grape R runs uh grape
jelly runs rather oh my God that
packaging looks good I'm about to also
they got the Strawberry Shortcake and
they got the pre-rolls the double doinks
man these ones right here are the Lemon
Cherry gelato that's a hybrid um and
look you can get 40% off right now 40%
off right now
um all you have to do is go to delt
munchies. use that promo code bootleg
Kev or bootleg uh you'll see it down
below all right and get 40% off your
order of $60 or more now this is
important because the sale ends November
30th so head on over to delt munchies.
comom get you some of that slushy juice
these are very good four gram blend of
live resin thcp and Delta 8 you can get
a 5,000 hits out of this bad boy plus
free lanyard in every bag Delta munches
bam Uncle may but that's bias though
Uncle Mayo know that he's first album is
one of the most slept on albums ever
Uncle Mayo is slept on period unle that
first album it's a [__] the whole
album's a concept it's literally like
one of the hardest concept albums he
gets out of jail the whole album is
about him getting out of jail and
there's just that album so crazy the
story I feel like AR story hard oh shout
out to Maya shout outs to Uncle Maya I
love you I just booked him uh he was at
my club like two days ago Phoenix with
my guy mkam out there yeah yeah he had
fun right I'm sure he's you know he's a
fun guy my boy had fun he's a fun guy he
is super fun guy shout out to mano um so
you said what's your favorite Foxy Brown
project uh honestly for me I'm not a a
project type of girl I'm like a single
so Brooklyn Anthem was that was what
made me be like I'm this way for a
reason she's a Brooklyn girl like
there's nothing wrong with me I used to
think that I was too agress people
always say you so aggressive you so this
you so that and then foxy made me
realize like no I'm not you know foxy
was aggressive as [__] yeah so I'm like
no I'm not I'm just from she was a part
of the firm yo like you know what I'm
saying like she was like holding her own
with Nas and a consistently yeah so the
thing for me is see I wouldn't say that
I grew up on Kim and Foxy music but I'm
from Brooklyn so that's like I had to
know who biggie was Kim Fox like I just
had to know so yeah I'm a student in a
game so I tap in and I study it but no I
didn't necessarily grow up on the music
like you know that makes sense um do you
have a name for your fan base Gators the
Gators yeah the Gators uhuh wow are they
toxic cuz I'm not toxic though no I'm
just saying some of these fan bases get
a little aggressive I've had little kids
folks come at me they're pretty crazy I
I'm not going to front though they might
go crazy on you if you like the Gators
yeah if you don't if you don't if you
growl at me they going to growl back
what does that mean oh like like H yeah
the death R Gator the death row cuz yeah
the death row what you mean why Gators
because my my skin is bulletproof so I'm
big Gator it just came about I did a
freestyle on a platform shout out to I95
I did a freestyle shout out to those
guys bar on I95 I was like 2020 I ain't
giving out no favors my skin bulletproof
[__] I'm big gator and then my fans
would just take it and be like big Gator
big Gator big Gator but before I tapped
into it I'm like can I really relate to
this name regardless of the skin being
bulletproof and I can because they very
patient and they they um warmhearted but
cold blooded have you had fans show up
to your shows wearing Florida Gator
merch like gear no likeo Jersey like
look Gators you know no I don't I don't
think so I don't think so I don't think
I ever caught that before you got to go
to Gainesville now I do Gainesville
Florida is where the Florida Flor show
me mad love though like I have a good
fan base in Florida though where where
in Florida have you performed um
Orlando uh
Miami Miami's nice somewhere else have
you been to the strip clubs in Miami yet
booby trap booby trap's a movie it's
also un it's almost unbearable booby
trap is a real thing where you're in
booby trap you're really trapped and you
can't leave and I don't like to party
but when want to leave the U are taking
forever to get there there's a line
outside it's [__] 700 in the morning
I'm tired I'm miserable Miser you be
what you I I mean after pulling an all
nighter and I'm on [__] jet lag from
the West Coast n no no and then you're
with this guy DJ AO he's a psychopath
good guy though I'm sure you've met him
I had a time in my life at booby trap I
couldn't believe I didn't want to leave
my team kept saying you ready to go you
spend a lot of money you oh no I didn't
no I didn't no I don't do those type of
things did you eat did I they got they
got food at booby trap um I don't
remember they got some of the best strip
club food in the country is in Florida
Miami specifically G5 has great wings um
uncle trick uh made sure he fed me when
I came out there his food was Trick
Daddy fed you what did he cook cuz you
know he cook I mean he got he got a he
got a spot I didn't know that yeah he
got a restaurant was it good it's called
Uh Sunday's what um Sunday eer Sunday I
remember I think he was on Cribs or some
show cooking some wild [__] you remember
that yeah he shout kind Florida like
pancake thing he was no I had some
turkey wings turkey wings did I was it
yeah I had some turkey wings uh are
those bigger than chicken wings it was
fire I've had a turkey leg I've never
had a turkey wing at like a restaurant
turkey no I mean that's why you got that
restaurant because I got to go I've only
been to like uh finger licking which in
my household turkey wings was a thing
but not for me I didn't like turkey
wings until I got older you got to go to
tootsies and get the fried lobster tail
while a lady massages you they have uh
they have non strippers there what type
of freaky eery is that no no no it's
tootsies tootsies is a legendary strip
club you know Drake said I'm in toot
shoulder rubs I've never I've never been
there so tootsies they have dancers and
then they have literal fully clothed
lady like Mass's so like some someone's
Auntie is in there like they'll rub your
back for like 45 minutes for or 45 bucks
I think it's for 30 minutes or something
like that or it's 45 bucks for 15
minutes and it's amazing so you're just
sitting there eating maybe the fight's
on maybe the Dolphins are playing and
then you got a lady giving you a real
massage like a real massage it's not
like no weirdo [__] like it's a real
masseuse oh really survive yeah oh I got
to go it's it's not a bad place I got to
go but booby trap is a movie for sure
yeah booby trap is a trap for sure you
know what I noticed when you go to the
Shri Club in New York it's more about
the bartenders than it is the
dancers is that fair oh that's a New
York thing yeah that's a New York thing
right yeah like bartenders might get
more love than strippers for sure yeah
um talk about like uh for you how like
cuz you've been putting out singles you
putting out Lucy's music videos all that
um how were you deciding like what went
on the album what was like hey let's
just drop this let's just throw this out
there it was very easy because it was
just me telling my story so the lineup
is step by step of my emotions so it
wasn't hard and I wanted to make sure
that my story was clear as day before I
take the next step like before me being
an artist I was shines before Lola Brook
I was Den's daughter before Lola Brook
so I feel like it's important for the
fans to know that and understand why I'm
even here today rapping so does your mom
like is she like super proud of you she
has to be yeah my mom is super proud
like she's a proud mom and sometimes
like I can't realize my moments but it's
all good because when my moms feel my
moments and I'm straight that's all I
need like thanks Mom for the job but
like I'm also thank you for blessing me
to like yeah for that support system for
me because a lot of people parents do
not once it come down you want to be a
rapper mm oh no you tripping but she
believed in me I feel like if you want
to be a creative like it it's very
helpful like whether you want to be an
actor a rapper or even like a comedian
or something it's like your parents are
either going to look at you like you're
[__] crazy or they're going to be
like hey whatever you need we got you
because I feel like most parents don't
they're like in disbelief of having a
child that may be a star like imagine
just having a child like the lottery
like I just know you as my kid right
exactly so it's like there's no way that
you're the one MH so you know some some
parents could push through through it
strive through it and some parents just
lock up and and they don't know how to
be supportive to they their child um how
do you how how we feeling about just New
York as a whole right now cuz obviously
you know drill's kind of been on the
Forefront the last few years in terms of
like what we hear about and then up up
north you got the gisel the guys you've
been doing your thing um Jen Carter and
them are doing their thing they I like
what they're doing cuz they're like just
kids having fun I love them together I
hope they stay together for real because
they all have different individual
personalities that fit together like
it's so dope like and like they like
I've had them on the show twice all
together and they're hilarious they're
so funny like their energy is so big um
I met all three of them recently at
Powerhouse I did Power House in New
Jersey and they energy was just so great
like I I rock with it I jack it say how
you feel like do you feel like New
York's in good hands right now with
yourself for sure New York is always
going to be in good hands even if we
like we not um Front Street with with
this [__] in music we just always going
to be there we always going to have a
comeback for sure so I'm I'm from
Brooklyn so I ain't I ain't letting up
hey that's fair has there been somebody
who in the last like year you realized
was like a fan of what you were doing or
was following you or someone who like
liked something that or just dm'd you
like a that was just surreal for you to
be like damn this person knows who I am
like they acknowledged my artart like in
2017 Meek uh P like Meek like Coan for
me Meek M yeah that's fire he Coan and
then growing up like he's the reason why
I'm really rapping like so you were like
a big Meek person yeah I was a big big
Meek fan growing up and I was like if he
could do it I could do it yeah
Dreamchasers or they did was doubt him
you know he was selfmade [__] doing a
battle rap so everybody didn't think
that he could cross over mhm and he
crossed over and I remember being in
high school walking around like yo he
gonna be the next thing I'm telling you
I'm telling you and then he started
going crazy did you see his uh his
latest the funk Flex freestyle that just
dropped I actually was I I was with them
but I had to leave because I went to my
um release party so I wish I could have
been you got to go to your release party
yeah I had to go to my release party
today but I I definitely was chilling
with Rick um I was just like yo
freestyling 4 minutes straight I'm like
this [__] is
like [__] 12 all over again I missed
it like that right there is
inspirational for me like i' be neing to
see that but you know it's online anyway
so I go just tap into it for sure so do
you have a friendship with uh with Ros
and meek at this point hey what up y'all
we got to stop the interview tell you
about our good Folks at King pom that's
right let me tell you about King pom man
it's all we smoking over here what I
love about King pom turpine infused
flavor in each one of these These are
the margarita now this is kind of the
wave I've been on recently these
Margarita ones are [__] fire
no tobacco no nicotine straight raw
organic fresh leaves um and what's dope
is they got the tip you squeeze the tip
you hit one of these boys and you just
get hit with that flavor man you get hit
with that flavor no matter how big or
small the Palm is you know what I'm
saying this is what's dope too uh King
pal if y'all don't know man they're one
of the leading Brands when it comes to
this real like organic smoke light
that's why I like them I like to smoke
clean nothing cleaner than a King Palm
so if you're in your hood you're in your
neighborhood you're in your
[__] City your area wherever
you're at go to your local liquor store
they're going to have King poms all
right so pick them up there you can also
go to 7-Eleven or this is what I suggest
you do right
now come on shout out to the king poms
man go to the website King pom.com if
you go to King pom.com you use the promo
code bootleg this is what we're doing
50% off whatever you order they got got
so much at King pom.com not only do they
got the
leaves not only do they got the
Grinders not only do they got the gas
trays they got them all the cones
50% off all the smoking accessories all
the leaves you need all the flavors 50%
off King pom.com promo code bootleg also
speaking of [__] you're going to get
some money off of our family our dogs
our are listen I'm going to uh Tampa to
go DJ for these guys holiday party Odd
Socks baby the holidays are here now is
the time to go to oddsock official.com
and use that promo code bootleg all
right use it right now and guess what
you're going to get 20% off at checkout
now the dope thing about odd Sox they
got all the crazy licenses they just
locked down Coca-Cola recently yeah look
at those they just locked down Hasbro so
they got Power Rangers
Transformers all that I mean look they
got cheit bro you know what I'm saying
they got Hershey's chocolate bro they
got WWE they got Breaking Bad they got
Top Ramen they got the drawers they got
the socks they got the slippers they got
the Hat they got the belt whatever you
need odd Soxs official.com load up for
the holidays gift odd Sox to your loveed
ones whatever they're into there's an
odd Sox for it oddsock official.com use
the promo code bootleg when you check
out save 20% off let's get back to the
interview shout out to the homies over
at Blue Chu man that's right blue Chu
everybody always ask me does blue Chu
work well you don't take my word for it
try it for free for a month by using
that promo code bootleg right now blue
chew has the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Calis uh it's all wrapped up
into a blue chewable form delivered
right to your doorstep in discret
packaging no doctor's
appointments uh are needed all right you
don't have to go into the doctor
everything's online go to blue.com all
right sign up for with that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free if
your dick ain't [__] it's time to get
a [__] again you know what I mean
you're dealing with a little erectile
dysfunction maybe a little anxiety at
work maybe you're stressed out maybe
you're just married to someone you're
tired of [__] let's be honest
sometimes you need a little extra you
know a little extra some some to get you
over the Finish Line get that blue chw
baby blue chw try the first month for
free they're going to give it to you for
free fre a month supply for free go to
blue.com use the promo code bootleg
right now thank me later let's get back
to the interview yeah like we like
that's family that's dope yeah that's
family for sure do you get a like being
family with Rick Ross do you get like a
Wing Stop card or
something I ain't I you know what's so
crazy I should have asked him for a
plate of lemon pepper wings man i' been
like hey bro like what's the point of
our friendship if I can't get some sort
of half off restaur like let me get a
gift card a gift card would be nice I
feel like he should have his w be asick
as mine cuz I got like a old white guy
wallet and every time he like yo thank
[Applause]
you you know what I'm saying don't hurt
you like lemon pepper is that the go-to
um I wasn't I got put on to lemon pepper
not too long ago maybe like two three
years ago and my first time eating it
was in Atlanta oh yeah yeah but what
spot in Atlanta I don't remember I just
remember having l pepper in Atlanta
though lemon pepper's fire it's fire
well done too well done mhm I'm a
buffalo guy but I I'll in there see I
used I used to do the Buffalo but now I
don't like I don't like it to be too
messy because I be working so much so I
need to eat things that's and then your
you get your nails done your nails will
be all orange underneath well but the
thing about me is I'm low maintenance as
a female so I ain't really are those
your real nails are these are these the
oh so those are your real your real boys
right there for sure shout out to you
yeah real so my wife's Mexican and she
you know she gets fake nails but she
eats Hot Cheetos and [__] oh so the
Cheetos and
sheot Cheetos lemons and pickles on a
plate n mind your business leave her
alone and nothing ain't hard to find
some water and soap she wash your hands
you know uh talk about uh obviously this
record with with Bryson is dope um shout
out to Bryson who doesn't do many
features no he doesn't do a lot so it
it's got to be you know dope to be able
to kind of like get a he's he's one of
them guys you know what I'm saying yeah
Bryson just was telling me like hey I
rock with your movement I think you're a
dop dope artist and he he did what he
could do he did what he do like he
always do he don't miss and I'm grateful
to have that because I know when Bryson
pop out it's a reason for Bryson to pop
out for sure he's like an introvert for
like big time yeah like he just I think
he's just more focused on music more
than anything yeah like it's not even a
it's not it's he don't focus a lot of
people a lot of artists focus on the
lifestyle as well but with him I feel
like he just just focus on the music
more than anything yeah thing um being
from Brooklyn are you are you like a
nycks or a net person or do you not give
a [__] don't put me in that don't I'm
I'm you want to get back from both teams
you want to do half time at both teams
right don't do me like that man but
listen shout out to the N shout outs
they're both really abusive relationship
fans I'm sure listen
I'm I'm I know the N is is is new right
you're from New Jersey yeah okay well
then it is what it is don't put me in a
sports thing I don't know I don't I
don't know you're not a sport I'm not
about to sit here and be lying to y'all
I just like to watch the game I don't
care what game it is I just have you
been to more Nets or Nicks games I've
been to more Liberty games honestly
shout out to the Liberty shout out to
the Liberties they just went to the
finals yeah get me but we did you go I
didn't I couldn't I couldn't make it I
wanted too don't do you remember when
Rebecca Lobo was on the Liberty do are
you I don't think you're no I'm not I'm
not like all the way just I just started
tapping into when the WNBA started they
had this giant white woman on the
Liberty her name was Rebecca Lobo she
played for the Connecticut uh Huskies
she was just this Giant mountain of a
white lady she was really good at
basketball she was good yeah how much
she was doing on on a game what points
you was putting up I can't I I'm I'm not
going to lie a you don't know that far
huh female basketball's gotten a lot
better recently it's no it's got really
good when I grew up it was like we had
like Cheryl swoops Lisa Leslie Rob Lobo
listen I love there was like there was a
part you know maybe 10 years ago it was
just hard to watch but now like you know
the a doing shout out to the Liberties
those my girls Laney you heard have you
performed at a game yet like any I I
Tred to I I try to do what I could do I
did Liberty I did next game I did I
think I did the next twice so you're
next fan [__] the next I'm kidding I'm
kidding they ain't had you perform [__]
them we we rocking with the Nets they
had you perform twice come on man Mel
Bridges is over there that's a for shout
out to the N they take care of me I
really love the they they really do take
care of me all the time shout out to
them and they just gave me a gift not
too long ago thank you what they give
you I can't tell you what n what gift
could a basketball team give you that
you can't talk about because it's it was
I could say how many it was limited and
it was only like five and I was one of
the FES was it a Jersey no it was it was
a package oh you got a package it was
huh was the TNN oh the in tournament
thing is is it
yeah listen your new your new album is
out yes then his daughter um everyone
should go support it are you going to be
uh hitting the road anytime soon of
course I'm trying to go on tour for sure
then his daughter got to promote
Dennis's daughter project that's the
only way it's G to move did your mom
obviously your your dad passed away but
is your mom like hey the next album my
name yo listen I'm telling you this
right now my mom's was like listen
Denis you doing too much bro you doing a
little bit too much what's your mom's
name Tisha so album Number Two tisha's
daughter tisha's daughter I'm not going
to tell or the deluxe the Delux how you
know yo listen all right cool you look
at me look at that Kev Kev done the
deluxe the deluxe ising T's Edition
there's a situation where I'm feeling
like a deluxe should be put out I can't
tell you when but a deluxe should be put
out Deluxe on the way she says I did not
say that she all all but said it I'll
tell you that much isn't a good idea
it's a good chance it it could be
happening for sure is it cold in New
York in
December no it's not okay well you live
so you're used to it it's [__]
freezing anyway appreciate you coming
through thank you for having me Kev I
appreciate it Lola Brooke boom fire yo
we're wrapping up an interview man of
course we want to shout out to our
family at harden baby Harden Las Vegas
celebrating their seventh birthday this
month so happy birthday to harden
uh want to give a shout out to the whole
family over there when you're in Las
Vegas you got to pull up the Hardy tell
them that the bootleg head podcast sends
you they're going to take care of you it
is the craziest selection of Premium
cannabis in the country all Under One
Roof you walk in and it's just a Vibe
beautiful butt tenders amazing smoke
just the illst merch you know what I'm
saying and it's right in Las Vegas right
in s City so you land in Vegas you about
to go gamble with your boys you get in
that cab you say take me to harden
they're going to know exactly where to
take you all right shout out to Hardin
go follow him Hardin Las Vegas or go to
the website Hardin vegas.com